ce film de smartphones donc en plus
derrière foyer un radiateur est ce qu'on
regarde bien une gros plans sociaux qui
sont au mieux parce que tu es tu si le
milieu ok quoi
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on va parler de caterpillar
des smartphones kate a pris la alors là
vous me voyez dans un environnement un
peu particulier parce qu'on peut faire
plein de choses à ce extraordinaire avec
ses smartphones smartphone extrêmement
résistant et là vous ne voyez en
détection de chaleur d'envoyer magie
chez aujourd'hui on va pouvoir faire un
tour on va regarder ce qu'on peut faire
avec ce nouveau smartphone notamment es
61 de caterpillar on va se projeter dans
un environnement que je ne connais pas
forcément le bâtiment la plomberie le
travail paris manuel
donc on regarde ça qui attribue le dire
est ce que vous en pensez aux
commentaires 4 vient de lancer un
nouveau téléphone de base le b 35 et
katché superbe très bonne connexion et
avec les applications intéressantes sur
très robuste solide et qui dure comme
tous les téléphones
après nous évoluons dans lesquels
téléphone dans les smartphones es31 le s
41 cas une très grande batterie et puis
le s 61 que le nom de montre et qui a
vraiment 3-3-3 unis qui sont la caméra
thermique
le capteur de l'air et la distance
on peut mesurer directement les
smartphones de vendre ça c'est le s60
dire vous voyez les sanglots d'être
effectivement si robuste parce que
l'idée d'un smartphone comme celui-là
c'est qu'effectivement il peut tout
encaisser alors l'idée ce n'est pas de
le jeter par les murs et par les
fenêtres parce que fondamentalement vous
allez finir par casser un moment mais
pour des professionnels qui travaillent
dans des environnements avec beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de poussière il peut
vraiment casser ensuite vous lancer dans
l'eau on a vu pas mal de on a vu des
vidéos présentant des cas d' usage des
personnes qui est rare dans un
environnement extrêmement poussiéreuse
vous avez un téléphone qui effectivement
est complètement recouvert de poussière
vous le racé dans l'eau vous en faites
ce que vous voulez c'est vraiment
l'accessoire un peu couteau suisse
on va dire pour les professionnels alors
professionnelle n'est pas que
professionnels et particuliers parce que
j'avais aussi que c'est qu'un
professionnel est toujours à particulier
il utilise son téléphone le soir et le
week-end aussi sur les 61 vous avez un
snapdragon 630 cadencé jusqu'à 2,2
giguère 64 giga de stockage 4 gigas de
ram et une énorme batterie de 4500
milliards eur avec une coup de charges
pour s'adresser à quelqu'un
pour essayer plein de professionnels
donc ça peut être par exemple les
artisans beaucoup d'artisans plombier
chauffagiste constructeur les personnes
qui vont réparer les toise et ces masses
donc agriculteurs aussi tous les gens
qui sont à l'extérieur qui n'ont pas
peur de lancer leur téléphone dans la
boîte à outils qui vont dehors avec des
températures extrêmes qui va toujours
fonction smart phones qui d'avoir une
très très grosse autonomie et sa pour
les professionnels c'est bien parce que
on imagine que d'étapes que des capteurs
thermiques laser de tous ces différents
capteurs ont forcément consommer un peu
plus de batterie donc derrière il faut
avoir de l'autonomie est une très très
grosse batterie c'est en tout cas c'est
plutôt cool avec les 61 ans vous pouvez
pas dans cette pièce là vous voulez
avoir tout de suite faire une cotation
pour un travail vous mesurer rapidement
vous ça va vous calculer la surface vous
dites il me faut tant que pape eu autant
de
tentant tapisserie et cetera vous pouvez
imprimer envoyer votre cotation tout de
suite à votre client par email voilà
c'est fait donc ce serait une mesure où
les airs par exemple le capteur de l'air
toujours utile vous êtes en train de
peindre vous êtes dans un endroit fermé
ça va vous avertir que l'air devient
mauvais dans vous avez échoué après
d'ouvrir d'aérer ou d'arrêter de
travailler ses terrasses est bien pour
votre votre santé et bien sûr la caméra
thermique des applications énorme énorme
donc pas au niveau de la ferme vous
pouvez voir la température vos animaux
même dans le mauvais chercher aux
animaux au grenier vous pouvez voir s'il
ya des souris vous pouvez aussi revoir
les fuites au voir toutes vos tuyaux etc
aussi n était pas de chaleur très très
très éthique dans les moteurs aussi par
exemple quelqu'un qui regarde les pertes
de chaleur dans certains endroits des
moteurs pour la photo il ya le vert de
la planète opération
donc les kamikazes sont extrêmement la
très large c'est à nous en trouvons de
jour en jour par exemple la dernière
fois que quelqu'un m'explique et c'était
lors d'un accident
des gens avaient exulté égérie de la
voiture et les services de secours
avaient pris la caméra thermique avaient
repéré de la chaleur sur un siège et
c'est à dire en fait y avait une
personne qui manquait dont ils ont été
la chercher en dehors c'était la nuit
vous avez ici un écran de 5 pouces il
tourne sur un android henriot et vous
avez ici un appareil photo 16 mégapixels
avec détection de phase et à l'avant un
capteur de 8 mégapixels un smartphone
qui est disponible dès aujourd'hui s'il
vous intéresse vous a mis un lien en bas
de la description au tarif de 899 euros
alors ya eu un autre smartphone un autre
téléphone de présenter le b36 5
il tourne sous caillou s alors vous avez
un écran couleur et en même temps une
antisèche et un écran couleur de 2,4
pouces q vga
l'idée si vous allez retrouver à
l'intérieur
twitter facebook
youtube des pouvoirs faire pas mal de
choses avec vous avez votre maps pour
pouvoir vous repérer là c'est un
téléphone extrêmement résistante micra
absolument pas c'est un petit peu la
donne de ce produit et ce qui est
intéressant si vous pouvez l'utiliser
comme une borne wifi
parce qu'il est 4g dont pour pouvoir
brancher votre ordinateur et votre
tablette vous connecter n'importe où on
pouvait compter sur lui alors il tourne
sous un qualcomm 8905 dual core cadencé
jusqu'à 1,3 g gars vous avez 512
mégaoctets drame et 4 gigas de stockage
une batterie de 1300 clients période et
à l'arrière vous avez un capteur de 2
mégapixels il a du bluetooth 4 points
est bien évidemment une certification
ip68 parce que l'idée a de ces
téléphones
c'est d'être très robuste et très
résistant parce que ce qu'on recherche
avec ses téléphones smartphones ou
téléphones de caterpillar
c'est de la robustesse de la solidité et
la durabilité
[Musique]
donc voilà pour aujourd'hui pour cet
event 4 fun ce je vous ai présenté ses
deux nouveaux téléphones les 61 le
smartphone et le téléphone levé 35
on verra si on peut détester un peu plus
tard en tout cas on voit
qu'effectivement ce sont des produits
qui sont nichées ils sont pas fait pour
tout le monde plus pur du pro mais en
tout cas des smartphones extrêmement
résistant et ça c'est plutôt cool donc
dites moi ce que vous en pensez en
commentaire est ce que vous avez déjà
utilisé des produits de caterpillar
prenait ce que ça pourrait vous
intéresser et qu'est ce que vous pensez
de tous ces outils vous marquez tout ça
quant à nous on se retrouve
[Musique]